สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensible  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ค่ะแล้วก็เรามาพบกันนะคะคือครูปุ๊กกับครู
ชิเเนี่ยมาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวัน
นี้คือวันอะไรคะครูชิวันนี้วันพฤัสบดีค่ะ
นะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14 ค่ะครูปุ๊ก
เดือนอะไรคะธันวาคมนะธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะ 12 ค่ะนะปี
พุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่
2566 ค่ะนะปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
คริสตศักราช
202  3 ค่ะค่ะก็วันนี้ครูปุ๊กมาพบกับครู
ชินะคะในวันนี้วันวันพฤหัสสบดีที่ 14
เดือนธันวาคมปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะนะค่ะครูปุ๊กวันเนี้ค่ะต้องคุย
กับครูปุ๊กค่ะก็คุคุยเรื่องอะไรคะครูชิ
เพราะว่าครูชิมีเพื่อนที่ขี้เหนียวมาก
เพื่อนที่ขี้เหนียวแล้วใช่ค่ะแล้วครูชิก็
บอกเาว่าเค้าเนี่ยเป็นคนขี้เหนียวเค้าบอก
ไม่เค้าไม่ใช่เป็นคนขี้เหนียวแต่ฉันเป็น
คนประหยัดอ้าวครูชิคะเดี๋ยวค่ะอเดี๋ยวค่ะ
อือหืออะไรอ่ะมาพูดเรื่องขี้เรื่องอะไร
นักเรียนจะรู้สึกแบบโอ๊ยมันสกปรกนะคะครู
ชิมันเหม็นน่ะไม่ใช่ขี้แบบนั้นค่ะ
อ้าคือมันเวลาเวลาเราอะไรที่มันรู้สึกมาก
ๆเนี่ยเราจะรู้สึกว่าเราต้องใช้คำว่าขี้
ค่ะเช่นขี้
เกียจเวลาอ่าไม่อยากทำอะไรเลยไม่อยากทำ
อะไรมากๆอยากจะนอนนอนนอนอย่างเดียวเนี่ย
เราไม่อยากไปทำไม่อยากไปทำงานเออขี้เกียจ
เนี่ยมันคำเดียวกันใช่มั้ยขี้เกียจไม่ใช่
ขี้เกียจอันนี้คำเดียวกันค่ะใช่มั้ยเคือ
แบบว่าโอ๊ขี้เกียจทำอ่ะไม่อยากทำงานเนี่ย
โอ๊ยอย่าเกลียดค้านดิเกลียดค้านต้องขยัน
ต้องขยันอย่าเกลียดค้านเราก็บอกเวลาถ้า
เราไม่อยากทำอะไรมากๆเราบอกโอ๊ยเราต้อง
ใส่ขี้เข้าไปค่ะให้มันรู้สึกว่ามากแล้วก็
ต้องเป็นสิ่งที่ไม่ค่อยดีด้วยใช่มยใช่ค่ะ
เหมือนๆคำนี้ค่ะโมโหโมโห
โมโหแต่ถ้าคุณอะไรอะไรก็โมโหตลอดเนี่ยใช่
มยรถติดโอ้โหโอร้อน
โอโหเอ้าคนเดินเยอะโอ้โหรำคาญ
โมโหมีแต่โมโหโมโหคุณนี้เป็นคนขี้โมโห
จริงๆเลยนะครูชิเหมอะไรที่มากเกินไปก็ชอบ
ใส่ขี้
อ่ะแต่ไม่ได้เเกลับไปห้องน้ำนะอ้าอันนี้
ไม่เหม็นใช่มั้ยขี้อันไม่เหม็นค่ะไม่
เหม็นนะคะเห็นมขี้เหนียวอหอืไม่ได้หมาย
ถึงว่ามัน
เหนียวโอ๊ยครูปุ๊กทำไมชวนคิดแบบนั้นคะ
เอ้าก็มันมีความหมายที่นักเรียนจะคิดได้
ไงกูปุ๊กพูดแล้วทำให้ครูชินึกถึงภาพเลย
ค่ะครูปุ๊กก็อยากให้ครูชิคิดอยู่โอ้โหครู
ปุ๊กอันนี้อันนี้ไม่รู้ว่าโอ้โหมีแมลงบิน
ด้วยอันนี้น่าจะเหม็นไงอันนี้ขี้จริงๆ
ออต้องหาไม้มาเอาไม้มา
เขี่ย
เฮ้ยเหนียวอันนี้จ้าเหมือนซุเปอร์กูเหรอ
คะเหมือนกันมันไม่ใช่แบบนั้นครูปุ๊กเอ่อ
ครูปุ๊กชวนชวนให้คิดอะไรที่ไม่ดีนะคะเอ้า
ก็ต้องให้นักเรียนเข้าใจไงแยกได้ระหว่าง
คำเนี้ยมันมีความหมายแบบขี้กับเหนียวมัน
คนละคำกันใช่มยอ่าที่ครูชิทำอยู่เมื่อกี้
เนี่ยนะอ่าอันนั้นมันขี้แล้วก็เหนียวอัน
นี้แต่อันนี้เนี่ยที่เรากำลังจะคุยกัน
เนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนกันเหนียวมากเลยค่ะดึง
ไม่ออกอันเนี้ย
เหนียวเหนียวกูณปุ๊กนี่คิดอะไร
คะภาษาไทยเนี่ยมักจะมีคำ 1 คำกับ 1 คำพอ
มารวมแล้วความหมายเปลี่ยนอเช่นแม่แล้วก็
น้ำเอามารวมกันแม่น้ำความหมายไม่ได้หมาย
ถึงแม่เป็นน้ำหรือน้ำเป็นแม่ไม่ใช่แบบ
นั้นอืความหมายมันเป็นเปลี่ยนไปเลยเช่น
เอา
ขี้เอาขี้กับเหนียวมารวมกันหมายถึงว่า
เวลาคุณจะแบบจะจ่ายอะไรอ่ะจะจ่ายเงิน
เนี่ยคุณจะคิดิดๆแบบอื้อหือมันมันไม่อยาก
จ่ายมันจ่ายยากอ๋อมันเหนียวใช่มั้ยมัน
เหนียวออกไม่ได้นะมันเหนียวเหลือเกินมัน
ไม่อยากจะจ่ายเงินค่ะมันไม่อยากจะจ่าย
เงินไม่อยากจะเสียเงินไปเลยอออันนี้อัน
นี้ 1 คำนะใช่ค่ะพอมารวมกันเนี่ยความหมาย
จะเป็นอีกความหมายนึงนะคะ
อืทีนี้ถ้าเราพูดว่าขี้เหนียวเนี่ยูชิ
เห็นเพื่อนูชิเนี่ยเวลาทำอะไรเนี่ยเขาคจะ
คิดเยอะๆถ้าต้องจ่ายเงิน
น่ะแล้วเาจะยอมจ่ายเงินนิดหน่อยและต้อง
ใช้เวลานานๆเบอก
ได้ครูชี้ยกตัวอย่าง
เช่นเราเนี่ยไปทำงานกับบริษัทใช่มั้ยแล้ว
บริษัทให้เราเนี่ยไปสถานที่นึงบริษัทก็
เลยให้ค่าแท็กซี่เพราะว่ามันดึกแล้วไงอ
กับบ้านเนี่ยอาจจะไม่มีรถเมล์แล้วอาจจะ
ไม่มี BTS ไม่มี MRT แล้วบริษัทก็เลยจ่าย
ค่าแท็กซี่ให้นะให้เรานั่งกลับบ้านสบายๆ
อืแต่เพื่อนคนเนี้ยค่ะเอาค่าแท็กซี่เนี่ย
เก็บใส่กระเป๋าค่ะอ้าวแล้วเ้าทำอะไรคะ
นั่งรถเมล์
อ๋อคือไม่เดินกลับนะไม่เดินกลับค่ะนั่งรถ
เมล์ค่ะแล้วก็ยอมเก็บเงินค่าแท็กซี่เอา
ไว้คุชิบอกเฮ้ยอันเนี้ยคุณไม่ได้จ่ายนะ
บริษัทจ่ายบริษัทจ่ายค่าแท็กซี่ให้เอ้า
บริษัทจ่ายให้ฉันฉันจะนั่งแท็กซี่หรือจะ
นั่งรถเมล์หรือจะเดินอันนี้ก็เป็นสิทธิ์
ของฉันเพราะฉะนั้นเงินก็เป็นของชันคูยโหย
ขี้เหนียว
อ่ะไม่ได้จ่ายเงินเองก็ยังขี้เหนียวไม่
ยอมใช้เงินน่ะปุ๊ปุ๊กเบอกไม่เค้าเรียกว่า
ประหยัดค่ะ
โอ้โหประหยัดกับขี้เหนียวมันต่างกันกัน
อยู่นิดหน่อยเองนะครูชิบางทีเนี่ยมันอยู่
ที่เราคิด
เนี่ยแต่ครูชิรู้สึกว่าขี้เหนียวหมายถึง
แบบคุณจะจ่ายเงินอะไรมันจ่ายยากมากแต่
เวลาคำว่าประหยัดเนี่ยเราจะรู้สึกว่าถ้า
เกิดคุณต้องจ่ายมากแต่อีกที่นึงอ่ะเอ่อ
ร้านสมมุติขอใช้ชื่อหน่อยนะคะร้านเว่นอีว
อนะคะขาย 20 บาท
ร้าน
เอ่อทอ
Super อ้าอ้าเค้าเป็นคู่แข่งกันไง
ท็อปซูเปอร์มาเก็ตขาย 18 บาทคุณก็มี
สิทธิ์เลือกไงเลือกที่จะประหยัดเงินอีก 2
บาทก็ไปที่ท็อ Super มาร์เก็ตค่ะ
นะหรือคุณจะซื้ออะไรเนี่ยตอนเนี้ยมัน 100
บาทแต่อีก 2 วันเนี่ยมันมันจะลด
ราคา 12  12 มันจะลดราคารอค่ะอีก 2 วันลด
ราคา
อ่าอันนี้ประหยัดหรือว่าบางทีเนี่ยเรา
เดี๋ยวนี้เราช้อปปิ้งตามนะไม่ว่าจะเป็น
ช้อปี้ Lazada อะไรอย่างงี้เนาะนะเราก็
อาจจะแบบเช็คราคาเยอะๆไงสมมุติว่าครูชิ
เนี่ยอยากจะซื้อกระเป๋านะครูชิก็อาจจะไป
ดูหลายๆที่เพราะว่าบางร้านเนี่ยราคาเนี่ย
มันแพงมันถูกกว่ากันนะอืยี่ห้อเดียวกัน
เหมือนกันเลยนะแต่ซื้อร้านนึงอาจจะแพงมาก
กว่านิดหน่อยแต่ถ้าเราหาไปเรื่อยๆบางที
เนี่ยจะมีร้านอื่นที่ถูกกว่าบางคนก็ยอม
เสียเวลานะที่จะหาอือืนะโดยเฉพาะแบบเวลา
ซื้อเสื่อซื้ออะไรรู้สึกว่าซื้อบ่อยๆบ่อย
ไงเราก็ต้องซื้อร้านที่มันถูกกว่าอืหื
อันเนี้ยประหยัดหรือขี้เหนียวคะอันนี้
ประหยัดค่ะประหยัดเพราะว่าเราเลือกใช้
เงินที่มันเซฟมันมันมันมันถูกกว่า 2 บาท
10 บาท 20 บาทอันนี้เราเรียกว่าประหยัด
เราไม่ยอมเราไม่จ่ายมากเราเลือกที่จะจ่าย
ช่วงเวลาที่น้อยอือฮึหรือเราจะซื้อตั๋ว
เครื่องบิน
เราจะใช้สิทธิ์โรงแรมเราจะใช้สิทธิ์ตอน
ที่มันประหยัดใช่มั้ยช่วงที่แบบว่า
เอ่อลดราคาโรงแรมลดราคาเราก็ซื้อไว้ก่อน
เลยอย่างเงี้ยอันนี้เราเรียกว่าประหยัด
ค่ะแต่ถ้าเกิดครูชิต้องไปเชียงใหม่อ้าว
ครูปุ๊กอยู่เชียงใหม่
อ่ะครูปุ๊กมีบ้านอยู่เชียงใหม่บริษัทให้
ครูชี้เนี่ยไปทำงานที่เชียงใหม่ครูชี้ก็
โทรศัพท์หาครูปุ๊กปุ๊กสวัสดีจ้าจำได้มั้ย
สัสดีจำได้มยชิชิออชี้อ๋อจำได้จำได้เอ่อ
มีเป็นยังไงมั่งสบายดีมยสบายดีแต่ตอน
เนี้ยบริษัทจะให้เราไปทำงานที่เชียงใหม่
เราไม่ค่อยรู้จักเชียงใหม่เท่าไหร่เราไป
พักกับปุ๊กได้มั้ยออได้ไปนอนที่บ้านัก 3
วันนะได้ๆๆ 3 คืนนะโอเคได้
เออแต่บริษัทให้เงินนะค่าโรงแรมค่าโรงแรม
แต่ครูชิเนี่ยไม่จ่ายค่าโรงแรมค่ะไปอยู่
บ้านครูปุ๊กฟรีอืน้ำฟรีไฟฟรีนอนฟรีกิน
ฟรีอันเนี้ยประหยัดหรือขี้เหนียวคะ
โหถ้านอนเนี่ยถ้าสมมุติว่าเออเป็นเพื่อน
สนิทกันแล้วไม่เจอกันนานอยากนอนคุยกัน
หรืออะไรแบบนี้อันนี้ก็โอเคนะแต่ถ้าูชิ
คิดว่าเฮ้ยมันจะได้เก็บเงินนะแล้วก็ยัง
กินฟรีอันนี้เริ่มคิดไม่ถูกละอันนี้ขี้
เหนียวละแต่ถ้ามานอนบ้านครูปุ๊กแล้วครูชิ
บอกเอ้ยปุ๊กไม่ต้องทำกับข้าวไม่ต้องทำ
อาหารไปกินข้างนอกเดี๋ยวเลี้ยงเดี๋ยว
เลี้ยงครูชี้จ่ายเงินค่าข้าวเอ่ออนี้โอเค
อันนี้อาจะเรียกว่าประหยัดไม่ได้ตั้งใจจะ
ขี้เหนียว
อ่าแต่แบบเนี้ยโอ้โหคิดแผนไว้เลยนะว่าจะ
เซฟจะจะประหยัดเงินจะเก็บเงินได้มากแค่
ไหนแล้วก็ไปนอนกับครูปุ๊กไม่ต้องเสียค่า
โรงแรมกินก็ฟรี
จะอันนี้ไม่ดีค่ะนะขี้เหนียวเนี่ยไม่ดี
ค่ะเห็นคูชิก็บอกเพื่อนว่าทำไมเคเป็นคน
ขี้ขี้เหนียวแบบนี้เาบอกไม่ๆๆเราไม่ใช่
เป็นคนขี้เหนียวนะเราเป็นคนประหยัดูชิบอก
ออๆๆคุณเข้าใจผิดแล้วประหยัดเนี่ยก็คือ
คุณจะต้องรู้จักใช้เงินใช่ไหมอือย่างถ้า
เกิดคุณจะต้องแบบอะไรล่ะไปนอนโรงแรมแล้ว
คุณเอ่อบริษัทให้นอนโรงแรมแล้วคุณเลือกไป
นอนห้องอะไรอ่ะพัดลมราคา 500 บาทอย่าง
เงี้ยนะคะะอันเนี้ยประหยัดถูกมั้ยเพราะ
ว่าคุณยังต้องจ่ายแต่จ่ายที่ถูกลงนะคะแต่
ถ้าคุณไม่จ่ายเลยเนี่ยครูชิบอกอย่างเงี้ย
เค้าเรียกว่าขี้เหนียวค่ะอือืเงินเนี่ย 1
บาทไม่ออกเลยไม่กระเด็นเลยครับผมไม่
กระเด็นออกมาเลยไม่หลุดออกมาเลยนะ 1 บาท 2
บาทไม่มีเลยค่ะอันนี้เค้าเรียกขี้เหนียว
ค่ะ
อื้อหืออย่างงี้ยังไม่เท่าไหร่นะครูชิครู
ปุ๊กเนี่ยมีเพื่อนที่ขี้เหนียวมาก
ๆเพราะว่าเวลาไปกินข้าวเนาะก็จะไปเป็น
กลุ่มใหญ่ๆหลายๆคนเนาอนะแล้วเราก็เวลากิน
เสร็จแล้วเราก็ต้องต้องแบ่งกันช่วยกัน
จ่ายใช่มั้ยอ่าอนี่ของเรานะออือ่านะแต่
ทุกครั้งที่เราไปกินเนี่ยนะพอถึงเวลาจะ
จ่ายเงินเพื่อนคนเนี้ยจะไปห้องน้ำ
เอ่อน้องๆคิดเงินค่ะเออขอโทษนะเดี๋ยวเรา
ไปห้องน้ำก่อนนะอืเขาไปห้องน้ำเช็คความ
สวยงามก่อนกลับบ้านหายไปเลยห้องน้ำใช่ค่ะ
ไปห้องน้ำแล้วก็จนแบบคนพนักงานมาเก็บเงิน
ไปแล้วนะเพื่อนหลายคนก็ให้เงินเ้าเพื่อน
คนเนี้ยไม่ได้จ่ายเงินเงินใช่มั้ยก็ไม่
เป็นไรต้องรอเค้าออกจากห้องน้ำอนะพอออกมา
จากห้องน้ำทุกคนก็เตรียมตัวกลับแล้วเนาะ
นะแล้วครูปุจะอืมเอ่อของตัวเอง
เอ่อ
อเออะๆ 120 หรออือ้ายังไม่มีใครจ่าย
เหรอเพื่อนเนี่ยเบอกว่า
อ๋อเรามีแบงค์พันเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวเราเจอกัน
คราวหน้าเนให้อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอหตอนนี้
แบงค์ 1,000 บาท 100 เอ่อพวกเธอออกไปก่อน
นะเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเราจ่ายให้อืมนะพอคราว
หน้าก็ไม่จ่ายอีกค่ะไปห้องน้ำเหมือนเดิม
ออเทคนิคเดิมใช่ค่ะออกมาแล้วก็ไม่จ่ายค่ะ
แบงค์
พันเหมือน
เดิมพูดเหมือนเดิมเลยใช่แล้วก็เพื่อนก็
เป็นอันรู้กันหรือบางทีเนี่ยก็ทำเป็นเฉยๆ
ออกมาแล้วก็อ่ะป่ะทุกคนพร้อมแล้วใช่มั้ยป
กลับบ้านอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเออหรือบางทีเนี่ย
เค้าก็เอ่อออกไปแบบมีแฟนมารับอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยออเราจะตามไปทวงก็ได้ยังไงล่ะูชิอ่า
เรากลับก่อนนะแฟนมารอแล้วเราก็ไปเลย
เอ่อจะบอก 100  120 มันก็ยังพูดไม่ได้เลย
นะนะบ๊ายบายแล้วเจอกันทุกคนแล้วก็ไปเลย
ใช่ไม่รอให้ใครอ้าปากพูดอะไรเลยใช่ก็บอก
ออตอนนี้แฟนมารับแล้วนะเดี๋ยวบ๊ายบายทุก
คนเดี๋ยวเจอกันคราวหน้าแล้วก็ไปเลยค่ะ
แล้วะทุกคนก็อืแต่ว่าคนที่จ่ายเงินเนี่ย
อย่างครูปุ๊กจ่ายไปก่อน
เนี่ยกี่ครั้งแล้วคะโอแต่ไม่ใช่ครูปุ๊กคน
เดียวไงนะเพะหน้าอีกคนนึงเ้าเป็นคนจ่าย
ใช่มั้ยเค้าก็ไม่ไม่จ่ายให้คนนั้นเหมือน
กันจนเราก็ไม่รู้ว่าเค้าจ่ายไม่จ่ายจนมา
เจอกันกับเพื่อนตอนหลังเนี่ยเราก็เริ่ม
คุยกันเนาะเฮ้ยอืเพื่อนก็เริ่มพูดบอกไ
เนี่ยไม่ไปกี่ครั้งไม่เห็นจ่ายเงินเลย
เนี่ยครั้งไม่รู้จะทวงยังไงจะทวงบอกว่า
เฮ้ยครั้งที่แล้วกินข้าวเนี่ยค่าข้าว 150
บาทอะไรอย่างเงี้ยจะไปทวงเาก็ไม่ได้ครูุ
ก็หะเออเหมือน
กัน 120 ก็ไม่
จ่ายเออที่บอกมีแบงค์พันแล้วก็เอาไว้จ่าย
ให้เนี่ยทุกวันนี้ยังไม่จ่ายเลยเลยใช่นะ
พอมาคุยกันหลายๆคนก็รู้ว่าอ๋อไม่ได้จ่าย
เพื่อนเหมือนกันอันเนี้ยแล้วโอ้โหมันขี้
เหนียวมากนะขี้เหนียวจริงๆอืคราวหน้าไป
กินข้าวไม่ชวนไปดีมั้ยเออนะเพราะว่าไม่
ยอมจะจ่ายเงินเลยนะเอออันอันเนี้ยค่ะไม่
ใช่ประหยัดนะคะขี้เหนียวค่ะนะคะแต่เพื่อน
กูชิคนนี้ก็เหมือนกันค่ะเคคขี้เหนียวแล้ว
พอบอกเค้าว่าอย่าเป็นคนขี้เหนียวสิต้อง
แฟร์ๆแฟร์ๆหมายถึงว่าเมื่อเรากินด้วยกัน
ก็ต้องจ่ายด้วยกันเมื่อเราทำอะไรก็ต้อง
แบ่งกันให้เท่าๆกันเสมอกันอืเค้าบอกใช่
มั้ยเค้าก็บอกว่าอันเนี้ยเค้าเรียกว่า
ประหยัดชิบอกไม่ใช่แล้วล่ะประหยัดตัวเอง
อ่ะตัวเองไม่จ่ายแต่คนอื่นจ่ายไงคนอื่น
จ่ายให้ตัวเองไงเพราะฉะนั้นตัวเองไม่
เรียกว่าประหยัดแล้วล่ะเรียกว่าขี้เหนียว
อืเค้าบอกว่าไม่ใช่ฉันไม่ใช่เป็นคนขี้
เหนียวฉันเป็นคนยังยืนยันว่าเป็นคน
ประหยัดอีกครูชิบอกคราวหน้าเดี๋ยวครูชิขอ
ประหยัดมั่งนะอืคราวหน้ากินข้าวครูชิขอ
ประหยัด 1 มื้อนะเธอจ่ายแล้วกันเคราวหน้า
เราไม่ค่อยมีเวลาว่าง
ลประตูอยู่นั่นออกไป
เลยอย่างงี้ขี้เหนียวจริงๆอืนะขี้เหนียว
จริงๆอ่ะกับบ้านดึกแค่ไหนนะบริษัทให้เงิน
ค่าแท็กซี่คุณเธอก็แบบรถเมล์
ค่ะแทนที่จะแบบปลอดภัยใช่มั้ยเป็นผู้หญิง
กลับบ้านดึกๆนั่งแท็กซี่บอกโอ๊ยแท็กซี่
แหละไม่ปลอดภัยนั่งรถเมล์มีเพื่อนเยอะอ๋อ
แล้วไม่ต้องเดินเข้าซอยใช่มยหรือว่ามี
หน้าหน้าตาเป็นอาวุธหน้าตาหน้าใครเห็น
หน้าตาแล้ว
กลูไม่หน้าตาเขาก็โอเคอยู่นะออแต่แต่ครู
ชี้ก็เลยบอกว่าต้องเข้าใจใหม่นะประหยัด
กับขี้เหนียวเนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนกันคชี้บอก
ไม่เหมือนกันใช่
มั้ยแบบประเภทที่แบบว่าเงินน่ะไม่ให้
กระเด็นเลยอ่ะไม่ยอมเสียเงินเลยอ่ะนะคะ
แล้วไม่ยอมเสียเงินเนี่ยแล้วไปเอาของคน
อื่นเนี่ยอันเนี้ยมันไม่ใช่ประหยัดแล้ว
ค่ะมันขี้เหนียวมากๆใช่มั้ยอืออืหรือร
หรืออย่างงี้คะแบบูชิใช้แบบ
ทิชชู่
ล้างมือเช็ดเสร็จแล้วตากเอา
มั้อันแล้วก็เอามาใช้ใหม่
อคิใช้แล้วใช้อีกใช้แล้วใช้อีกอย่างเงี้ย
หรอคะใช่ค่ะก็ก็มันมันมันยังไม่สกปรกไง
มันเปียกน้ำไงแล้วก็มาซับน้ำแล้วมันเปียก
มันเปียกน้ำไงเปียกๆๆก็เลยผึเอาไว้นะพึ
เอาไว้เดี๋ยวมันก็แห้งแห้งเสร็จก็เก็บมา
ไว้ใช้ต่อไงอืขาวหน้าล้างมือก็เอาทิชชู่
เก่าเนี่ยมาซับมันแค่เปียกน้ำไงมันยังไม่
สกปรกอืมอันนี้ประหยัดหรือขี้เหนียวคะขี้
เหนียว
ค่ะมันมากเกินกว่าประหยัดแล้วเนาะนะก็จะ
เรียกว่าขี้เหนียวเห็นมั้ยอะไรที่มันมากๆ
เกินไปเราต้องใส่คำว่าขี้เข้าไปให้มันรู้
สึกว่าอีไม่อยากอยู่ด้วยคนนี้ฉันไม่อยาก
อยู่กับเธอเลยเพราะเธอเนี่ยประหยัดจนเกิน
ไปจนเราเรียกว่าขี้เหนียว
แล้วเงินนิดเดียวเงินหน่อยเดียวก็ไม่ให้
กระเด็นเลยเนี่ยแล้วยิ่งเวลาถ้าเกิดมีงาน
สัมมนางานสัมมนาอย่านักเรียนเรียกสอ่าใช่
มยเราแบบสัมมนาเหมือนกับทุกคนมาจากออฟฟิศ
เข้ามาด้วยกันแล้วมันก็จะมีเค้กมีขนมมี
กาแฟ
โอ้โหพี่คนนี้ค่ะกระเป๋าเา้าแบบกระเป๋าเข
ใหญ่มากนะพอทุกคนกินหมดแล้วเสร็จแล้วเบอก
โอ้อันนี้มันเยอะนะคะมันเหลือขอกลับบ้าน
นะคะเอ่อๆอันนี้ไม่ใช่ประหยัดแล้วค่ะแล้ว
ก็ไม่ใช่ขี้เหนียวค่ะูชิ
อันนี้เรียกอะไรคะขิ
งกขิงก
ด้วยงกเนี่ยมากขึ้นไปอีกนะคะก็คืออยากได้
ของคนอื่นด้วยใช่ของคของตัวเองไม่ออกแล้ว
อ่ะอย่าอยากได้ของคนอื่นเอามาเป็นของเรา
อีกอันนี้งกค่ะเอามาเอามาค่ะเอา
มาตัวเองก็ไม่จ่ายนะของตัวเองก็ไม่ให้ไม่
ยอมจ่ายแล้วก็ยังอยากได้ของคนอื่นด้วยอัน
นี้เรียกว่าขี้งก
อื้อหือแล้วถ้าขี้เหนียวกับขี้งกมาเจอกัน
จะเป็นยังไงคะ
โไม่มีคนคบดีกว่า
ค่ะไม่ไหว
ค่ะไม่ไหวจะ
เคลียร์ไม่รู้จะเคลียร์ยังไงเวลาไปกิน
ข้าวด้วยกันไม่รู้จะอธิบายยังไงพี่กินไป
จานของพี่เนี่ย 250 บาทเอ่อแต่ฉันกินไป
แค่ครึ่งเดียวเองนะ
อ้าวครึ่งเดียวเนี่ยร้านก็คิด 280 นะคะ
ไม่ได้คิด 150 เมื่อไหร่
ล่ะโอ้แย่เลยทีหลังชวนกันไปกินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ลัดหน้าใกล้ๆออฟฟิศจานละ 30 บาท 40 บาท
ได้มยอย่ามากินแบบนี้แพงเอ้าเออเออที่
เหลือนี่ครึ่งนนใส่กล่องกลับ
บ้านเอ้าปุ๊กไม่กินแล้วเหรอนัน่ะเไม่กิน
แล้วอิ่มแล้วขอๆใส่ถุงกลับบ้านเอาไปให้
หมาขอน้ำจิ้มด้วยมั้ยขอน้ำจิ้มด้วยหมาชอบ
กินน้ำจิ้มมันยังไง
เนี่ยอีกคนนึงกำลังกินอร่อยเลยอออันนี้ก็
ไม่กินแล้วใช่มยอิ่มแล้วเนอะเอากลับบ้าน
น้องๆเอานี้ด้วยใส่ถุงอันนี้จะขี้งกเกิน
ไปแล้วนะ
คะอันนี้ยิ่งไม่น่าครบค่ะขี้เหนียวก็ว่า
ไม่อยากครบแล้วเจอขี้งกเนี่ยโอ้โหไม่อยาก
มีเพื่อนเป็นแบบนี้
ค่ะไปไหนด้วยบางทีแบบอ่าอยากจะ
เอาอยากจะเอาถุงค่ะมาปิดอคนนี้คนนี้ไม่ร
รู้จักใครเหรอคะคนนี้ไม่รู้จักนะคะไม่ได้
มาด้วย
กันเคยเห็นมั้ยมีถุงพลาสติกเตรียมไปเวลา
ไปงาน
ปาร์ตี้แล้วเวลาจะกินก็แบบตักมาเยอะๆแล้ว
ก็แล้วก็ใส่ถุงใส่
ถุงทำเหมือนจะกิน
ะ
อุ๊ยสะดุ้ง
ค่ะ
เคยเคยเป็นค่ะสะดุ้งเลยเนี่ยพอครูปุ๊กพูด
แล้วแบบทำให้ครูชิสะดุ้งเลยโอ้โหูชิ
เนี่ยเค้กของโรงแรมนั้นอร่อยค่ะครูชิกิน
แล้วแบบโอ้โหเดี๋ยวตอนตอนบ่ายคอฟฟี่เบรก
ไม่มีเค้กขอสักถึงชิ้นเปิด
กระเป๋าใส่ในกระเป๋าเลยเหรอคใช่
มันมีก่ไม่ใช่ค่ะมีกล่องค่ะเค้กมันอยู่ใน
กล่องค่ะกู
ปุ๊กคิดว่าไม่มีกล่องโหครูปุ๊กไอเดียดี
มากคราวหน้าเวลาไปงานโรงแรมต่างๆคุณชิจะ
เตรียมกล่องไป
ค่ะู่ชิคิดว่าเพื่อนจะเลิกครบคูชิก็ตรง
ทีู่ชิเริ่มขี้งกถ้ามันเป็นอาหารแบบแบบ
เป็นโต๊ะจีนเนอะเจะจะมียกอาหารมาทีละ
อย่างเนาะมีออเดิฟเดี๋ยวก็มีอาหารเป็นเมน
คอรสอะไรแบบเนี้ยเค้าก็จะยกมาทีละ 1 จาน
แล้วก็ทุกคนต้องกินด้วยกันแต่คูชิบอก
เดี๋ยวๆๆๆๆแล้วก็ใส่ถุงใส่กล่องเก็บอัน
นี้ไม่โอเคนะคะถ้ากินด้วยกันูชิครูชิถาม
ไม่กินแล้วใช่มั้ย
คะคือถ้าเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์เนี่ยเพื่อนยังไม่
เท่าไหร่นะเพราะว่าูชิเดินไปแล้วก็ตักใช่
มั้ยเพื่อนอาจจะไม่ได้ชอบแต่มันไม่ได้แบบ
เอาของในส่วนของเขาไปไงกุชิเคยเห็นแบบว่า
เพื่อนในโต๊ะจีนด้วยกันเนี่ยโต๊ะจีนเนี่ย
ก็จะมีมีมีเหล้าใช่มั้ยแล้วหลายๆคนเนี่ย
เพื่อนคนนี้ก็รู้นะว่านั่งโต๊ะนี้แหละ
โต๊ะนี้ไม่มีใครกินเหล้าเลยนะคะมีครูปุ๊ก
นั่งอยู่ครูปุ๊กไม่กินเหล้าครูชินั่งอยู่
ูชิไม่กินเหล้ามีคนนี้นั่งอยู่ไม่กิน
เหล้าไม่กินเหล้าขอนั่งโต๊ะนี้แหละนั่ง
เสร็จพอกินไปได้ครึ่งครึ่งครึ่งทาง
50% ก็จะบอกว่าเอ่อไม่มีใครกินเหล้าหรอ
งั้นเราเอากลับบ้าน
นะคนไม่กินก็จะบอกว่าเออเอาไปเลยเอา
ไปแต่ปกติปกติอ้าน้องโต๊ะน้องก็ไม่กิน
เหล้าเหรอคะขอ
นะ
น้องก็เออโต๊พี่ก็ไม่กินไม่ใช่เหรอคะเออ
พี่กินค่ะพี่อ่ะกินขอเล่า
นะฟรี 2 ขวด
และดูโต๊ะอื่น
อีกดูโต๊ะอื่นอีกค่ะครูปุ๊กเออน้องไม่ทาน
เหล้าเหรอคะครูชิเข้าใจแล้วเดี๋ยวนี้ไม่
มีแบบนี้แล้วนะเดี๋ยวนี้โต๊ะไหนจะกิน
เหล้า
ต้องไปขอเจ้าภาพแล้วเจ้าภาพก็จะบอกโอเค
ครับเอาไปครับนะคะถ้าโต๊ะนั้นไม่กินเหล้า
จะไม่เอาเหล้าไปวางอ่าหรือว่าเป็นโรงแรม
เขาก็จะเสิร์ฟเป็นแก้วเนาะเไม่วางเป็นขวด
ไว้ให้แล้วเดี๋ยวนี้เพราะจะมีคนขี้งกแบบ
คูชิ
อยู่ไม่กินเหรอคะขอนะ
คะแล้วก็ไม่อายด้วยนะหน้าตาเฉยเออครูชิก็
เนาะอันนี้ก็ไม่น่าครบหมดนะครูปุ๊กเ้ยมี
อย่างเดียวประหยัดนะเอ่อประหยัดเนี่ยยัง
น่าครบได้อยู่แต่ถ้าเมื่อไหร่เป็นคนขี้
เหนียวจ่ายเงินก็ไม่ค่อยจ่ายเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยไม่น่ารักแล้วประเภทแบบขี้งกเอา
ของคนอื่นด้วยยิ่งไม่น่าครบใหญ่ค่ะอ่าไม่
น่าครบก็คือไม่น่าเป็นเพื่อนค่ะนะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเลิกเป็นเพื่อนเลย
ค่ะไม่รู้จักกันค่ะออนะแต่วันนี้เคือใคร
ครูชี่คะวันนี้นหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะนะก็คูชิก็
คิดว่าเข้าใจจแล้วว่าประหยัดกับขี้งกมัน
ต่างกันค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นครูปุ๊กมาการันตี
ว่าเพื่อนครูชิเเนี่ยขี้เหนียวค่ะแล้วครู
ชิขี้งก
เ้ยไม่น่าบกกันหมดเวลาแล้วถึงเป็นเพื่อน
กันได้สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนขอบคุณค่ะคุค่ะพบ
กันใหม่ในคลิปต่อไปนะคะบ๊าย
บาย